[Music]
hello how about my health leg
andrés gonzález with the most
outstanding headlines for today august 14 the
clark county school district
saying that about 97% of their
jobs are filled for
the next school year however  there
are approximately 615 vacant positions
in the county compared to 750
during the same period last year
but district wide that was the
highest number of vacancies since 2014
last night the school district board of directors
unanimously approved a plan
for internet connection in homes with
the company to cox with a sum of 4.8
million dollars the board also
approved other technology measures so
that all students have access
from their homes which cost
around 2 million dollars the
district is  contacting the
families that need it most
and talking about help, the community also
does its part to support the
students  Latinos so that they have
a computer a few days before the start
of classes
we know that there are around 415
families that need one so
far 70 were distributed
last week nevada blanca of about 5000
dollars to help with this collection of
computers families will be able
keep these devices instead of
just using them temporarily for
more information visit the
facebook group yes yes it is for fathers and mothers
and now we move on to the weather forecast
we will see a rise in
temperatures for the weekend
reaching 110 degrees there is a
heat alert that begins today at
noon and will last until
next week take precautions and avoid being
exposed to the sun for a long time
have a great weekend I am
in 3 gonzález and this was about the
news program  now in Spanish
[Music]